ces mesures effectivement en permanence
où on fait la grande fête parce qu'on
retire puis ensuite on remet ces mesures
qui finalement sont contradictoires
permanente d'un côté de l'autre
finalement ces mesures entre le pass
vaccinale le confinement le couvre-feu
tout c'est l'ensemble finalement des
choses qui a abandonné contribuer à un
sentiment de mal être dans la population
qu'il ne faut pas négliger ses travaux
avec la prise de risques
comme ça en attendant tanger
med i come back
130 étudiants le même soir perturbant
que
ça va bien mais tout cas où l'arrêt de
tous les dîners qui te dépasse à
batz-sur-mer n'y a pas respecté les
galaxies suicide comme ça
suffit
non mais c'est bon
la
brique par brique ce qu'est ce qui se
passe là bas on a failli me serais super
mario et ses environs
[Applaudissements]
en
attendant
fabrice trop bien je t'aime
fabrice à brice mais les dossiers
bon écoute et non mais j'adore j'adore
me dit bilou il savait que cette semaine
à venir n'en est pas là j'ai
l'impression qu'il reviendra plus à leur
mercie confessera vallino c'était un
plaisir pas
exceptionnel qu'est l'amour
régime juste si tu me permets importante
de malaisie juste pour dire
on m'a appris à être humble il faut être
en blanc il faut accepter les opinions
différentes il n'y a rien de pire que
tout le monde à voir ses seins pointe le
même point de vue ont fait la richesse
ses comptes nous avons que nous sommes
capables d'avoir des personnes qui ont
des regards différents un signe
d'intelligence eux c'est de les accepter
aussi et de débattre je ne pèse pas
d'accord parfois avec une personne c'est
l'intelligence en accepter et d'être
capable de les entendre et de
d'honorer un signe d'intelligence un
signe social qui est ok c'est ton point
de vue je le respecte on n'est pas
d'accord mais je le respecte
[Applaudissements]